let me turn on the
turn on the microphone
uh
that we have this is the an executive
session
[Music]
um
the interim study Bills or the resources
Recreation and development committee uh
we might as well might as well start
from the very beginning as well someone
has a question or a
comment
the no one
on House Bill
426 relative to Shoreland septic systems
uh representative harp you ran a
work session can you
he says I have to uh should recognize
you uh for to present the uh
the recommendation of the uh that
subcommittee work session thank you Mr
chair
um I had submitted a report to Heather
on the results of the subcommittee
session I'll read that report briefly
um representative Spang spoke about her
two-year Shoreline septic system
commission and did submit testimony to
the subcommittee representative gottlie
and expressed concerns about short-term
rentals and how it stresses septic
systems representative Healy supported
local control representative Harvey
boleya success that it suggested a study
committee I supported the board of
realtors concerns initially a motion was
made to recommend future legislation
that failed another motion was made to
not recommend future legislation that
passed by a vote of three to two for
this session I make a motion that this
matter not be recommended for future
legislation
that motion or not do not recommend
recommended recommended by
representative harp uh seconded by
representative Harvey bolia uh will is
we first of all do you wish to you have
already spoken you wish to speak on your
motion
I think I've said uh what I'd like to
say on Mr chairman thank you of
would you like like to speak on your
motion if I'm going to move the sun the
sun your second no thank you
my chair recognizes uh representative uh
spank thank you very much
um I was on the subcommittee and
um it seemed to me that the conversation
happening on the subcommittee was
counter to the final recommendation
um I think that everybody in the
subcommittee recognized that this was a
serious problem
um there was a little bit of discussion
about whether the way the bill actually
uh proposed to solve the problem was the
right approach but as we know it's not
the bill that we're talking about it's
whether there is a problem that needs to
be solved there was some conversation
about how it might be better if it were
solved if a bill were put forward that
recommended that it'd be more of a
locally controlled thing
so it occurred to I was surprised by the
vote because it seemed to me that the
subcommittee had felt there was a
problem had felt that there was a
solution that could be explored
um and I I so I would strongly recommend
that we change the committee's
recommendation to take on this very
serious problem and keep working on it
um
representative Harvey bolio suggested it
needed more study but this bill came out
of a very thorough two-year commission
that studied it I don't think another
commission is necessary but if another
bill is put forward where alternative
Solutions can be explored I think that
that would be adequate and badly needed
is there anyone else on the committee
every representative yes yes thank you
Mr chairman I would agree with
representative Spang I think that one of
the things you have to take a look at is
that there is a problem out there having
been a town planner in a Lakes Community
uh you know we have serious problems
with Shoreline septic systems there was
a two-year commission that addressed
this issue and studied it in depth and
the recommendations that they came up
with are pretty much what you have here
in this bill and to study it further
really solves no problem
um you know maybe some minor amendments
to this thing to take in some of the
concerns that some of the members have
here would be in order but this is this
bill came out of a two-year study to a
direct address a problem that we here in
New Hampshire spend millions of dollars
on both at the state and local levels we
spend a tremendous amount of money to to
keep our Waters clean
and if we just sit there and say we're
going to do nothing
we're not addressing the issue and we're
really letting our constituents down
um you know New Hampshire is successful
because we have such a great environment
here and to just let it go we're going
to destroy that and we're going to lose
that advantage that we have
I think this is a bill that that really
should have further consideration and a
bill should be introduced as an
accession to to address this issue
um and I would be happy to work with any
members of the committee that are
interested in furthering a bill for the
uh just let me let me first decide first
see if anyone else wishes to speak does
anyone else
representative Smith then representative
all are aware that there are issues with
non-point source pollution which is in
many cases septic systems and we all you
know I don't know of anyone who doesn't
want our Lakes to be clean and you know
which supports tourism which supports
healthy lives there is E coli in some
Lakes
um that is preventing people from
swimming and causing a health hazard so
although I agree that this bill itself
as written is causing problems I do
think there is a solution that all sides
can agree on and so I would say future
legislation could try to bring those
stakeholders together to find a way to
get to yes and in which case
um future legislation not the one that
house bill 426 is definitely an order
representative Spang
just quickly I wanted to address the
concern that uh representative Harr
brought forward
to the real
and the Realtors have told us
after the original hearing and then
after this hearing that they're very
anxious to work with us to solve this
problem so I think that that indicates
that probably there is a good uh
opportunity for us to come together with
the Realtors to solve the problem if we
continue to study it
okay
oh I'm sorry
representative Vale thank you Mr chair
um I'm going to be voting against the um
motion to not recommend the bill and I
just wanted to reiterate that we're very
aware of these issues and at this point
I think we have a an important
responsibility to protect clean water
and we've spent the last two years
finding ways to try to keep our water
safer and make it safer and this one is
clearly indicated
um
and so we do need to stop our declining
water come water quality
and I do think that future legislation
should be addressing that thank you
well I just have one thing to to say I
want to assure people that due to the
uh structure of the interim study uh
procedures they're
there are minority reports are not
allowed
so representative Smith and myself we've
talked and we have come to an agreement
that the any do any this uh any minority
minority thoughts on issues will be
mentioned in any final
report
just so that all
all ideas are will be will be presented
so uh you know it isn't that uh it's
gonna it's not gonna be just one way
so the report but uh but only only the
all we're going to be voting on is the
the motion right now uh is
representative uh Creighton
yeah thank you Mr chair just a question
on procedure
um
this vote if we say okay this bill is
uh
it does the right thing in terms of
protecting water but it does it in a
wrong way
and we say okay this is this bill it
doesn't make sense from that perspective
that does not preclude another bill from
coming in saying we're going to protect
water in a different way maybe one that
the Realtors would have input into
and I'm just I'm trying to understand
the exact procedure
uh in actuality in in reality
what we say hear and do here does not
affect future legislation whatsoever
uh somewhat all it is it's a I have in
my time here
which
is not as considerable as some but uh
it is fairly considerable I don't
believe I've heard
ever any testimony that oh this bill was
not uh it was not recommended for
for future studies so you really can't
study it now uh or if you for future
action so you for so we as a legend a
future legislature could could couldn't
do anything what we want we can do what
we wanted with it so uh
it so the actual outcome
of the of what we
of what we were going to going to put
out we're going to our of our work
product will probably be a
go into a file somewhere
for reality
is it being seen no one else will the
okay representative harb yes
representative Huff
yes representative golds
representative Horgan
representative Creighton yes
representative Dodge yes
clerk votes yes representative Healy yes
representative Mayville representative
post yes representative Smith
representative Spang no representative
grassy no Representative gottling no
no representative Cohen
he's not here okay
representative Kelly is not here
representative Moran
is not fair
and representative Eagan is not here
uh representative Egan okay
okay representative Cohen okay I thought
I said that representative Colin votes
no okay no thank you
okay so that's um and representative
One Two Eleven yeses and
okay six
and representative harb oh
write the first draft of the uh
report
happy to do that okay
okay
oh that doesn't go good all right all
right now next up
item is house bill 1167.
establishing a maximum contaminant level
for perfluorinated chemicals in surface
water
um
the
uh I think
there's a this this uh I'd like to
recognize uh Mr deers
uh
who's
just to give us an up uh an update on uh
the where the on the des's position on
this bill
and uh
we we were looking to
get some of your guidance and help us on
making our final decision decision great
thank you Mr chair for the record my
name is Ted deers I am the assistant
Water Division director for the New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services and it is a tremendous pleasure
to be in front of you today
um so uh as you recall from uh previous
testimony Des was not supportive of this
bill largely there was some technical
difficulties but also the the primary
reason is that we are in the process of
creating the very thing that this bill
would have us do which is to create
surface water quality standards for pfas
compounds where we are in that process
which has been long and tortured I will
assure assure you from my side
um is that we are within uh I think
probably a week of having a draft of
that out on the streets a red line draft
of our 1700 rules that will include the
four pfas compounds that have mcls URL
become painfully familiar with that
those will now be included as water
quality standards will apply to Waters
20 miles Upstream of surface water
intakes so this is on its way we gave a
uh an update to our commissioner
yesterday
we are finalizing that red line draft
and we will be scheduling uh some
stakeholder meetings to occur on that
over the next month we anticipate being
in rule making by the beginning of the
year
which would have these rules come into
effect sometime in 20 or mid first half
of 2023. so that is the intent
um that is where we were headed this
will go through the rulemaking process
you all will have an opportunity through
GL car to see it again and
um uh you know we are looking forward to
getting this uh in the in the can
so um if there's any other questions
about that I am very happy to uh include
you all on that red line version uh when
we uh when we have it out that will be a
non uh that sort of non-formal
rulemaking version that is a draft but
it will be one that has been pretty well
vetted over the past couple years
through a variety of different
stakeholder opportunities so
um at this point there really shouldn't
be any surprises
okay just then as a follow-up just to be
be certain you would not you would not
have any heartburn if we did not
recommend this bill for future
legislation
thank you for the question we are uh
like I said I think that we are have
this well in hand uh as a department we
take this seriously
um the number of bills that have been
recommending this is a testament to the
seriousness by which You all take it and
so uh we do not think that additional
regulation is necessary we've gotten the
message
um and uh and and the product will be
delivered
okay thank you guys any other questions
of uh Mr dears
representative Smith
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
deers for um taking my question which is
uh one is um when will there be public
hearings
yes thank you for the question
representative Smith
um we anticipate a public hearing will
happen
I would expect it would be in January or
February at this point that would be
when we first published the uh the
proposed rulemaking so we would very
soon thereafter within probably it has
to be you know within
60 days or so I believe is the rules so
we would have that hearing I'm us I'm
thinking it's going to be January maybe
early february-ish
um and so that will occur so we will
have a public hearing on this but
additionally
we have
um a long-standing water quality
standards advisory committee which has
some has hundreds of people who receive
the emails on that
um generally those folks who work in
your communities uh the they put people
who run wastewater treatment plants and
water treatment
so um as well as their Consultants all
sit on uh you know receive those emails
receive that information those are
widely that call is widely widely
attended and has opportunities for
virtual attendance as well so we'll um
you know send an opportunity out for you
all to see that and that'll be that'll
be an opportunity for the experts in
water quality and the implications of
water quality to be able to um to let us
know what they're thinking in an
informal way prior to the formal
rulemaking process which includes that
public hearing okay follow-up Mr chair
for a follow-up so I did I hear that you
absolutely no I I would absolutely love
to have uh this committee um it is an
opportunity for you all to learn
um all about uh the excruciating detail
of water quality standards uh in this
Fair State okay and then one more
follow-up for a follow-up thank you
um you testified that EPA is kind of
going in a good direction as far as
setting uh pfas water quality standards
do you is that moving along at all I
would don't know that I have
characterized it as a good direction but
I would definitely say that they are
going in a direction uh so what we
anticipate happening is that we
anticipate that EPA is also going to
start a rulemaking process on mcls that
is for drinking water recall uh that New
Hampshire is light years ahead of many
other states in the country on this
issue so these rules are really being
focused the the effort is being focused
on the rest of of the nation uh where
this hasn't gotten the attention that it
has here
um so
so we're not sure where that's going to
end up we do anticipate that but if if
we think that the state rulemaking
process is uh is tortured uh try try the
federal rulemaking process so we think
that that will be a long effort uh
before those mcls become Rule and we
don't know what those numbers are going
to look like they have not yet released
those but there will be we do know that
that will be happening sometime around
the beginning of the year okay thank you
you
any other questions by members of the
committee
representative Smith do you have a
motion yeah I make a motion to not
recommend for future legislation uh at
least this year anyway because DS seems
to be doing their job
for a second
do you wish to speak to your motion uh
representative Smith
I think we uh yes thank you Mr chair
um I think we all understand the
importance of um mcls and rules getting
passed regarding surface water I know
that um in my district Plymouth the
water and sewer company was very upset
when these bills were introduced because
they just felt like things were it was
going to be a really bad situation for
Plymouth so I think that allowing this
process to play itself out and I'm
assuming that the people from all the
different water and sewer districts are
going to be are in the stakeholders
group so I think this is a good
anyone else with a wish to comment on
the bill well representative Cohen did
you wish to speak to your second I'm
sorry oh yes I think uh Mr deers gave us
an excellent excellent explanation
what's going on and that the intent of
the bill was being met and that at this
point we don't need legislation to put
that effort in motion it's well under
control right now
okay is there anyone else who wishes to
speak
seeing none will the clerk please call
the roll
yes thank you chair uh on House Bill
1167 motion not to recommend
representative harp yes representative
Huff yes representative Gould
representative Horrigan representative
Creighton yes representative Dodge yes
clerk votes yes representative Healy yes
representative Mayville yeah
representative post yes representative
Smith
representative Spang
representative grassy representative
gottling
representative Cohen yes
right I'm just going to call a name
representative Connors
representative Vale
yes
representative Kelly
not here representative Moran not here
and representative Egan not here so
that's uh 17 years zero Nays motion
uh yes okay
so again next time
uh
14 40 relative to surface water quality
standards
for perfluorinated chemicals
don't go away
Mr deers
thank you
Mr chair uh 1440 we provided testimony
um about this bill uh we provided
testimony that we were opposed to this
and largely the reasons are there are
technical defaults uh technical uh
challenges within this bill uh the way
that it uh addresses this especially the
way in which things are um
added together
um and so and again the way that this
will ultimately come together is through
our water quality standards which I just
spoke about so
the one other point I would just make is
that um EPA this this refers to uh one
of the parts of this bill is that it
refers to the effect of pfas on aquatic
organisms I will also report that EPA
has now told us and told the states that
they are working on uh guidance for the
states on setting pfas standards for
Critters so that is going on and will
progress this is an effort that will
eventually get published as something
called 304 a guidance three or four a
guidance become part of what every three
years the state we go and look at our
water quality standards if there is new
304 a guidance from EPA we are obligated
to use that as part of setting our water
quality standards and if we don't want
to use that we have to have very good
scientific rationale for not using that
so it is an extraordinarily large
project of national implication to look
across all of this and it in New
Hampshire would never have the capacity
to actually do all of the science
necessary to look at what is the effect
of pfas on all of our aquatic organisms
so it is important that EPA take this on
and as we've heard now that they intend
to over the next year or so develop
these criteria for aquatic organisms and
then at like I mentioned as part of our
federal process with EPA we would be
obliged to bring those into our water
quality standards so this bill is
essentially
um it's saying to do what is already
being done uh and so we don't think that
it needs additional regulation uh this
is something that I think one could look
at um you know in the next session to
see what the progress is is happening on
this but this is something that is in
the works
are there any other questions of Mr
deers
representative grassy
um yes Mr cheers I think you you
basically brought up one of the
contentions I have this you're saying
that we could look at next session
possibly or later on in the second year
but if this bill was available to you uh
in January for an amendment to maybe
address some of the things that are
coming down from the federal government
as well wouldn't there be value in that
you thank you very much for the question
the the challenges is that nothing is
going to be sort of ready for prime time
from the federal government in January
we're a year out from that because even
the mcls that they're developing will be
draft so those won't be adopted there
won't be a thing yet and it's in terms
of the 304a guidance for aquatic
creatures again we won't even see a
draft of that for another year so
there's really nothing
the only thing that we would be
certainly I think happy to do and we
will be doing with the committee you're
going to have a lot of new members in
the committee uh next year and one of
the things that I've recommended to the
chair and offered to the chair is that
we would be happy to come in and talk
about where all of these things sit
across these different efforts there's
been a whole plethora of bills that have
looked at these issues there's lots of
moving parts to this and there's lots of
different activities going on between
the state government the federal
government great uh there's a great
article in on HPR this morning about
about soil standards soil remediation
standards again there's progress being
made across all those activities I don't
think that a bill is necessary to do
that but I certainly hope we'll have the
opportunity to address the committee in
the next session to give an update on
seeing none
representative harb would you I'll ask
you for a motion
based upon Our Testimony I would
recommend not recommended for future
legislation
not recommended
representative harb do you wish to
speak any more on your motion
now just to reiterate based upon what we
heard during our initial testimony and
hearing and what we heard today from Mr
deers
um I suggest it's not ready for prime
time and that we just say not
recommended for future legislation let
the job be done thank you
would you like to speak on your second
representative grassy
yes Mr Mr chairman after the testimony
of Mr deers I would also recommend that
we not recommend this I have introduced
this as an LSR but I will be going down
and taking it out I introduced LSR just
in case there was you know the state
hadn't gone any further on this I think
we're making efficient progress on this
okay
seeing none
am I seeing none of my bad eyes
seeing none will the clerk please call
the roll
not recommended on not recommended for
1440 representative harb yes
representative Huff yes representative
Gould
representative Horrigan yes
representative Creighton yes
representative Dodge yes clerk votes yes
representative Healy yes representative
Mayville representative post yes
representative Smith
representative Spang
LED or she's um
not present representative grassy yes
representative gottling yeah
representative Cohen yes
uh representative Connors is not here
representative Vale yes representative
Kelly is not here
representative Moran is not here
representative Egan is not here and
representative friends Zulu not uh he's
not he's not here not uh representative
renzullo votes yes okay that would be
sick
16 yays to zero names motion passes
motion passes yeah
yeah okay moving on
uh
one is
okay
1452 I was built I was Bill 1452.
renaming the Department of Environmental
Services the Department of Environmental
Protection
and assigning the department oversight
you know I'd like to hear from the yes
yes uh morning all for the record Mark
seeonborn assistant commissioner New
Hampshire Department of Environmental
Services
uh just uh following up on previous
testimony
uh Des the commissioner and I are very
much opposed to this bill despite I'm
sure well intentioned by the sponsors
the two elements of it the renaming
has a cost associated with it
um that is unnecessary not to mention we
believe the current name is much more in
the spirit of the New Hampshire approach
to these issues versus the proposed for
the other element as stated previously
um we this is uh this is a language in
search of a problem that doesn't exist
we have all ability we need to access
area is if we need to test we have never
had a problem
and we don't feel we need this authority
to make sure we are doing our proper
regulatory responsibilities so again
while well-intentioned we would uh
sincerely hope that you all would move
not no need for future legislation on
being
seeing none
representative Smith you have a motion
um I make a motion to not recommend for
by representative Harvey bolia
uh do you wish to speak on your motion
representative Smith
well of course thank you Mr chair
um
I'm not even going to speak to the name
change because I think that we heard
enough about that and the cost and it's
it's completely different than the rest
of the bill which is more of more
interest I mean I think it's really
important that people get their Wells
tested but I do believe that people have
that option and if we were to pass
legislation uh requiring Des to
inspect and test private Wells we would
be giving them policing Authority or
they would have to call in the town
compliance officer every time they
wanted to do that and it's not just like
checking the Wellhead it's going into
their homes to check the faucets in the
kitchen and the bathroom and stuff so
that's not good and also the cost of
doing uh wait I had some other notes
where are they
right now people can have their water
tested and if they're in areas that has
been noted for pfas I believe that in a
lot of times that is paid for by the
state
and the other thing I wanted to bring up
is that and I think representative
renzullo can say more about that is that
we did pass legislation that became law
to La this past session to open up the
opportunity for private homeowners or
private well owners to get grants or
loans
for remediation if their water tests
positive for pfest so I think that you
know doing it on a voluntary basis and
as we heard from Des during the initial
testimony people want to know what's in
their water they want to know if their
well is contaminated with pfas and so
those maybe few people who do not want
their water tested
that's their right but otherwise most
people the majority of people are taking
taking it on to have they want their
water tested so
so I don't think this needs future
legislation
thank you anyone else wish this uh wish
yeah I would I I would like to like to
like to say that there is a program
going on now where homeowners can
uh if if pfas is found in their in their
Wells uh at a in a out of compliance
that they the state does and will
uh offer offers you a uh basically a
loan and uh it's not actually it's not
alone it's a grant and it's uh it's uh
you know I know I'm taking advantage of
it myself right now I was surprised to
find recently that uh I uh my name
neighbor who was selling this uh home
had to do have to have a pfest I had to
have water testing which is normal for
sales and turns out
uh he had pfas in his wealth which
nobody knew nowhere near anything any
other issue any other uh area where
there's uh pfast
uh so we were notified by the state
because we were within five was it 500
feet of his well and my well had a uh we
had pfas in it as well uh most most of
it there was one that was out of out of
compliance and so
good uh so we had the water test tested
and that's what it came out and
lo and behold we found out that there
was this this program
and I'm saying wow so uh it and other P
I make certain I've made certain other
people in my town I've even broadcasted
on the uh on the uh
Pub on the public our public channel
that this is available and people are
wanting to know about it I'm getting
uh people want people who have nowhere
near where I live I want to have their
Wells tested so there's no there's not
there's nobody saying no we don't want
our well tested there are people who
want their well-tested so and should get
it so uh you know and you're looking at
somebody who's a convert so
uh that's again that's uh just
further for the record okay uh is there
if not on the motion to
not recommend
will the clerk please call the roll
yes thank you uh for Bill 1452
representative harb yes representative
Huff yes representative Gould
representative Horgan
representative Creighton representative
Dodge yes the clerk votes yes
representative Healy yes representative
Mayville representative post yes
representative Smith
representative Spang it's not here
representative grassy yes
representative gottling
representative Cohen yes
Connors is not here and representative
Vale
representative Kelly is not here
representative Moran is not here
representative Egan is not here and
representative renzuela yes
okay so that is uh
16 to zero motion passes
thanks to the committee now I have to
get to GNC so okay much less friendly
crowd
okay
and uh all right I'm gonna
skip over right now uh uh for
498 because because I wanna
uh get to get to everything that uh
uh
representative deers may have to have
uh want to testify on so I'm going to
1498 unless that
just somebody here for it uh and go
uh are you will you be speaking for uh
okay I'll okay I'll open up uh you know
the
of hearing a house bill 1602 relative to
perfluorinated chemicals in drinking
water
chair recognizes Mr deers
thank you very much again for the record
my name is Ted deers I'm the assistant
Water Division director at New Hampshire
Des
um
we did we we certainly uh agree with the
the the intent of this which is to make
sure that people uh in daycare uh
schools and licensed child care
facilities are are drinking good water I
mean that's I think that that goes
without saying uh there are some major
problems with this uh this bill and
um this really had to do with the fact
that and this is now I I believe that
there's actually some negotiations in
the work in the works on some future
legislation that will come up that's
already on a different track but that
the problem is is that most of the a lot
of the the facilities that look at
um
uh child care and schools are on are
already on
Public Water Supplies
so so this idea that somehow we would
the public water supply is already under
the MCL requirements so the water that's
coming out of the Taps is already being
tested at schools and day cares for that
purpose so that is already going on
um at uh because of the programs that we
already have
so that really is the challenge to that
was the primary challenge to this bill
is that
um it is important to uh
to only test the source of the water and
not the the actual uh and not the actual
Taps and and the other issue with that
is that it's not like it's lead where
it's coming out of the pipes where it's
coming out of the the spigots so there's
really no reason to go and test actual
you know the delivered water it's really
um and so the other uh issue is that it
really we should only be testing those
facilities that do not get water from
Public Water Supplies so and that is now
ongoing and I think that we reported you
got a report uh in uh from this from Des
in June this committee got a sent a
report on our testing results from
across the state so you you I think are
well aware that this is already underway
um and finally the actual regulation of
pfas or any other compound for schools
and day cares is not a des
responsibility it's actually a DHHS
responsibility
so this bill would dramatically change
would have dramatically changed the
entire structure of how those day cares
and schools are being regulated for
their Public Health not just what the
children are drinking but everything
else about the whole public school
system and the safety of that for our
children is currently in the hands of
the public health officials Des is an
environmental agency and we do some
Public Health they are a public health
agency and so it is much better to have
that there we advise DHHS on their
practices they use the numbers that come
out of what we do but changing the
entire structure of the way that we
handle public health for for our most
vulnerable populations that is a that is
a very very big change which this bill I
don't and the testimony to which really
didn't take into consideration the
enormity of of that change so there are
efforts now afoot to be able to work on
that issue this is not going to go away
because it is an important issue but in
terms of this bill and the current
effort there is not a need to move this
forward so that's my take on it and I'm
representative grassief yes uh Mr deers
um if without this bill do you have the
ability to test private schools and
child care centers
thank you for the question
representative I think that as as uh
representative uh renzulo noted and as
the previous testimony just noted we
have no shortage of ability to go test
things
um if we have if you're within 500 feet
of a known pfas source or pfas detection
we go and test those Wells so there is
not a problem with us getting in and
testing uh daycares if there's a reason
to do so so this is something that is
ongoing and you've also seen that we've
tested now thousands and thousands of
wells
and we are PR those have been
prioritized based on where where we know
sources and where we have detections as
we get those detections we draw those
circles those circles you know start to
intersect we start to have a better
understanding of where we're headed so
there are
um so so we will continue to be doing
that there's no shortage of either
ability we have no shortage of dollars
to do that at this point which is really
fun to say and we uh and there's no you
know shortage of of personnel or or or
other desire to do that so again that's
going to continue on a pace I don't
think I don't think that this is an
issue that that is is right now uh one
that we need to to deal with from a
any further questions for the democracy
no no question
representative Smith thank you Mr chair
um
when
BS Bill uh the discussion of
requiring Des to inspect private Wells
our homes with private Wells
um
I thought that we need you needed
policing authority to to do that testing
if people
hadn't asked for it is it different for
private schools
thank you for the question
um because we don't regulate all the
private school public health stuff I'm
not sure that no the precise answer but
my understanding is is that DHHS has the
authority to require any kind of testing
that is needed for those those
um you know day care and and uh in
schools you know I think this is really
important question because
oftentimes that you know a daycare can
be everything from the Boys and Girls
Club
to you know uh basically an in-home uh
daycare system so it's really important
that that DHHS is the one who tracks all
of that otherwise we were just we would
be in the realm of just somebody's
private well so there is in fact a whole
regulatory structure for those in fact
um just personally my son was a private
school teacher a daycare teacher a big
six foot one Burly guy with a beard who
was taking care of the babies uh the
baby section
um so anyway he was it was pretty funny
but um they were visited very frequently
by DHHS and by other agencies to look at
their facilities and we're very
constantly under supervision from those
agencies
thank you
Chris
representative uh yeah now you basically
what you said was here is that they get
inspected by DHHS and I'm quite familiar
with that my wife having run daycares in
his child care centers for if I say
daycare since she gets mad at me but
child care centers for a number of years
and still still doing that as well but
DHHS doesn't test their water and I'm
not aware of any requirement that they
would be in testing their water for that
should this bill maybe be amended to
direct instead of having Des do the work
having DHHS do the work
instead
um because you know so that it's in part
of what's included in their requirements
for licensing
um I understand the the complications I
certainly wouldn't want to take the
public health issues out for other
issues that they do but getting into
water quality isn't something that DHHS
has the expertise at doing but maybe
this bill could be utilized to to take
so so
um
I don't believe that there's a
representative from DHHS here behind me
so I I Hazard to speak on their behalf
what I would just say is that I think
what you've noted is that this probably
shouldn't be a Department of
Environmental Services responsibility I
also understand
because I know that we're actually
writing a fiscal note right now for an
LSR that there is an LSR on this already
so I know that there's already work
going on and that's one of the key
pieces of that um of the LSR that I know
that we've already received the request
for a physical note for so my suggestion
is is that
um we're that this is already well
there
I was under the impression and this that
if uh that that
daycares had to have their water tested
at a periodic basis and if not that was
if they did not do that that that had to
be it is that had to be uh they had to
notify their uh clients or their
customers that that fact is that
again I don't have a wealth of
experience in the that that part of it
so maybe potentially representative
grassy knows the answer to that but I
can certainly find that out and get that
to you it was my assumption that
um
well let me just look at my notes Here
so the department this is what I had
from our notes and what we testified on
last year over the course of this
session is that DHHS is actually working
on this right now this is something
that's where I think the nature of the
of the the the the the fiscal note that
I just mentioned to you is that there
are already
um uh there are already
resources and being put towards this
Mr chairman if I may just address that
as well I know that they we have been
doing they are doing lead testing and
that's been something that that the
Department of Environmental Services has
been doing but that is the only
requirement that I'm aware of that they
actually go out and test at the waters
when we pass the bill for lead testing
and there were a lot of I got a lot of
complaints from My Wife and others that
are involved in the and because it's
just an additional requirement they have
but they they have been doing that for
any other questions by members of the
committee
seeing none of Representative grassy are
you uh
looking you you would like to have is it
your uh contention that you would like
to
uh
Mr chairman I I would like to see this
bill uh recommended for further
legislation and what uh I think that
there is a problem that exists out there
and it's something that we shouldn't
address uh the form that I think uh Mr
deers had said is that there's another
bill out there someplace and I think
that this would just be in support of
that if if need be
um I know I have resubmitted the LSR and
I think that there are certainly some
changes which uh Mr deers has
recommended that I will be looking at
introducing into that bill
um so I I would certainly recommend uh
further uh further legislation
yeah that that puts you know puts us in
an interesting
conundrum in that
recommending a bill that we would have
no the the
uh
the subject of which would we would have
no uh interest in
other words we'd be strictly a DHHS
issue
uh
nice ex
representative Smith yeah well Mr chair
anything involving pfas and clean water
uh should be of interest to the
committee whether or not the bill comes
to us or not that would be my thoughts
it's just what I really meant decisions
to say was that the the our function
would uh does not would such that it
would not be something that we would be
taking a uh
an interest or a
or our function was does not require us
to
uh legis to examine that legislation
so uh so we would be we would be uh if
we went ahead and recommended future
legislation we would be recommending it
for somebody else
uh if we
uh that so it's one that I've never
faced this is a somebody must have faced
this before some committee but uh we
haven't I'm just throwing it out for uh
discussion uh represent representative
grassy yeah Mr chairman I think that you
know one of the things is the corundum
that we have here is that we never know
where the bill is going to go I mean
we've gotten some strange bills here
that we said why are they here and it's
up to leadership to where they send
particular bills I mean this could be a
pfas bill and if it is a dealing bill
with pfas and testing of water quality
in child care centers and schools
private schools that it certainly could
be a bill that came here but then again
it could be a bill that goes to another
committee for some reason it could end
up in education it was a major bill that
we had this last year uh dealing with
lead testing that ended up in education
and it was uh you know interesting thing
but we talked about it and uh and we
ended up talking about it in our
community here at the end of the year
but you never know where these bills are
going to go and I so I think that us
making a recommendation wherever that
bill happens to show up it shows that
this committee is supportive of
uh any other discussion on this on this
bill
okay Mr chairman yes I'd have to speak
against
recommending future legislation based
upon what we've heard and the fact that
this is a two-part Bill about renaming
and the other part of wrong Bill no it's
not
can we skip that one
no it's
we voted we voted that we already killed
that one well based upon what Mr deer
says I I don't think it really should be
um recommended since there are already
other legislation pending and fiscal
notes being written uh I would not
support uh recommendation for future
legislation
do anyone else wish this uh is
is is that emotion
do you make are you just speaking to
that or is that emotion
I wasn't sure if we had a motion no
there is
so I'll make my Roshan my motion not to
recommend future legislation for this
is there a seconds in a motion
and you've already really you've already
spoken on your motion I haven't no need
to speak any further thank you Mr
chairman representative Creighton nice
to speak
on your second anyone wish to speak uh
on this on this bill
it's a motion presented
if not will the clerk please call the
roll
not recommend
okay for not recommend on 1602
representative harb yes
representative Huff yes representative
Gould
representative Horgan yes representative
Creighton yes representative Dodge yes
the clerk votes yes representative Healy
yes
representative Mayville representative
post yes representative Smith
representative Spang
representative grassy
representative gottling
representative Cohen no
uh representative Connors is not here
representative Vale no
representative Kelly is not here
representative Moran is not here and
representative Egan is not here and
representative uh no
no okay so let's excuse me
Excuse me yes yes
and
one two six
no's motion passes
okay
all right uh it's just going moving on
adding several
well
adding several perfluorinated chemicals
to the list of per and polyfluoroalkyl
substances with maximum contaminant
levels and establishes a cumulative
total for the maximum contaminant level
of per and
polyfluoro alkyl substances Mr deers
thank you very much uh Mr chair the um
the department
um
was uh was not supportive of this bill
for a variety of reasons uh some of
which are very technical
um the fact that this adds two chemicals
one is pfba and one is pfbs
the problem with this is that the number
that was recommended for pfba is several
at least two orders of magnitude lower
than what the toxological uh in uh the
toxicological evidence would suggest it
should be so that seems to fly in the
face of making good science-informed
public policy secondly for pfbs the
number is very high which is probably
means that um there's going to be if
there if we would ever find this it
would already there would be some other
pfas compound that would be so much
lower that this would be irrelevant so
that one again is one that we don't have
also very much toxological evidence for
it all and so we would be making a
number which is at this point
essentially a screening number which is
really not what mcls are supposed to be
these are all things that are being
looked at by EPA as part of its current
science effort and so we'll get informed
by that
the final thing and we've testified on
this many times is the department is
very uncomfortable with setting a
combined pfas limit
and while at the face of it it sounds
reasonable the problem is is that each
of these different pfas compounds for
which we have mcls have different kinds
of toxological effects so some affect
one part of the system of your of your
body others affect other parts of your
system adding them to together is not
really understanding the toxicity by
which they're actually looking at how
they affect the human body and so we
think that this again flies in the face
of having uh I think a very good science
informed public policy for these
compounds
and this is something in particular that
the science the National Science Academy
is looking at and we will see additional
reports based on the combined uh effect
of pfas compounds in the next reports
that are released when MCL when EPA
releases its draft mcls so all of that
is going to be happening all that's
going to be coming out we'll see some
better information the department is
certainly open to any of that
information as it makes recommendations
to the future of how we're going to
any questions by members of the
committee
representative Smith
uh thank you Mr chair and
so dears for taking my question and this
does not talk about well my question is
not about this bill in particular but I
just wanted to clarify
um the bill that set the MC the law that
may set the mcl's uh for the force pfas
substances did that bill also author or
was there another bill that authorized
Des to uh or mandated whatever the word
would be to set mcls for things that
science came out and said were dangerous
to health
you know to to if they found other
prefast substances that were a problem
in New Hampshire that you would be
charged with setting levels for them or
doing the research on that with the
toxicologists
thank you for the question the one of
the things that's a requirement is that
we are we are doing periodic reports to
the legislature on pfas issue and that
is one of the things that we look at all
the time so as new research is coming
out our state our toxicologists
um uh John patalia who I believe has
been in front of this committee uh
previously he is always in contact with
uh both a regional group as well as
National groups that are looking at the
science as it emerges so as we learn
about these compounds for example Gen X
is under there's a significant amount of
research going on about that
and so as those compounds are understood
better as we have the the scientific
rationale to back those up we will be
making recommendations for future mcls
there are thousands of pfas compounds we
know a bit about a half dozen or or
maybe maybe 20 or 30 that we know
something about
understanding The Chronic these are
generally chronic
effects they're not acute effects that
makes it very very hard to study so to
the extent that we have other biological
models that are looking at these
um they're you know looking at the
effects on different
um species and the how those can
actually be then ramped up to the human
effects is work that is is still ongoing
and we'll see a lot more of that this is
a lot of funding going on to pfas
science right now so I expect that we'll
see that more of that but the answer is
yes we are required under various
different pieces of legislation in the
past to report back to the legislature
on what's going on in the the world of
pfas
any other questions by members of the
committee
seeing seeing none
representative Smith
I make a motion not to recommend this
I will second
yep
do you wish to speak on your motion
uh no I think I've said what I need to
say
um
on my second I concur
uh beings seeing no one else to speak
will the clerk please call the roll
or the motion is not recommended on Bill
1618 representative harb yes
representative Huff yes representative
Gould
representative Horgan yes
yes representative Creighton yes
representative Dodge yes
clerk votes yes representative Healy yes
representative Mayville
representative post yes
representative Smith
representative Spang
representative grassy
representative gottling yes
yes representative Cohen yes
representative Connors not here
representative Vale yes
representative Kelly is not here
representative Moran not here
representative Egan not here and
representative from Zulu
yes
okay
uh next bill is moving down the down the
list
uh isn't it so we can
get represents the deer is out of here
as soon as possible as he can uh how's
Bill 16 20. you know uh I'm going to
speak on that identifying part of the
Merrimack River as a protected River
do you wish to speak to that
thank you very much for the opportunity
to speak on this bill
um this is 1620 this would have added
the middle section of the Merrimack
River by uh by statutory
um uh vote rather than going through the
actual nominations process that is laid
out in statute so uh the department
suggested that maybe that we had a
process in place for this to happen and
if the good folks uh through Manchester
wished to go through that um that that
was afforded to them and that there are
reasons and I think you heard testimony
here by many people that there were real
good reasons for going through that
process to vet all the different uh
people who might be affected by it and
allow them a voice in that process and
that is essentially both a local state
and both a local and state process that
includes both the department and
ultimately this committee and the
legislature so that approach
um when we heard that the community
entities themselves while they weren't
necessarily opposed to the idea they had
not gone through this process they
haven't had the ability to hear from
their stakeholders either and so the
idea was is that if people really do
want to go through that on the middle
part of the the Merrimack that there
should be an approach to do so that
followed the normal statutory process
that said there were also elements of
the statute as it was approved in 1990
um that how were potentially problematic
today so while the department and I
think many people testified that we
should keep the designations of the
Merrimack the way that they are there
was some language in the existing law
that talked about limiting withdrawals
for pennichuck water works as well as
some other language that was put in
which is really sort of archaic
um it today if in 1990 when people were
thinking about this was a brand new
program that was brought forth by some
Extraordinary People to build a a
program that says hey if communities
really think that they have a special
resource there should be additional
additional protections additional
opportunities to protect that River in
the future and we have 19 rivers that
have gone through through that process
and so these designated Rivers have that
ability but at the time in 1990 there
was a great deal of fear about what this
would do to Future development about
what this would do to other aspects
including
um you know sort of water withdrawals
for drinking water that we would you
know be drying up the Merrimack River
we now today fast forward you know 30
years we have great programs in place to
protect water quality we've gone through
30 years of this program that's been
highly successful people believe that
they have a voice that no one is sort of
trying to do something that is untoward
to the communities that sit around these
Rivers so we think that there's an
opportunity here to remove some of that
archaic language to
um and and the primary reason for that
is really about comes back to the pfas
issue that we've just been talking about
and Water Supplies in the southern part
of the state
this is really critically important time
right now because of the loss of Water
Supplies to pfas and because of the
general pressure on the southern part of
the state places like Salomon and and
plastow and Windham and Atkinson and
Hampstead places which we would refer to
as having unfortunate geology those
places that don't have enough water to
support the the really important
development that occurs in the southern
part of our state
it's important to build the flexibility
into that moving forward so we would
suggest
um that potentially this might be a bill
that you might want to recommend to move
forward for future legislation not to
address the middle part of the Merrimack
and its designation as a designated
River but rather to address the language
uh in the in the existing language in
the bill and potentially remove that
language so that there's a lot more
flexibility related to dealing with
future water supply problems in the
southern part of the state
that's all I got to say about that as
Forrest Gump would say
anyone wish to ask a question
representative Smith thank you Mr chair
and thank you Mr deers for taking my
question
um you refer to the different uh cities
and towns such as Salem Hampstead
Wyndham and I am aware that uh through
the drinking and groundwater trust fund
when I served on that we
um
there was an agreement made that they
those towns would get well either have
build new wells or get water from the
pennichuck water work works I believe
and so has that been affected by this
statue that is archaic
is that is that prevented that from
happening
thank you very much for the question the
answer is not yet
okay so the answer is that as we look to
this and and there are currently
discussions afoot to talk about bringing
additional pipes under the Merrimack
River
um and looking at those service areas
and who's going to service which Which
towns in the future you know where the
different franchise areas and all of
that
if you ask pennichuck today and I think
Don Ware or maybe it was um uh Boyd
Smith uh talked about this during the
the testimony on this particular bill
they have not yet run up against that
that problem
but they may in the future and so that
is the reason why um this been
recommended both by uh the Water
suppliers as well as by other folks
who've been involved that we go ahead
and take care of that uh before we
actually get to a point where there's a
problem
thank you
we this bill as written which focuses
specifically on a section of the
Merrimack River real uh
is
not ready for prime time and
the way it was put together it should be
it would it would not be recommended
uh
my concern is that the chain the what
why why does it need to be in
what what value is it putting it in
putting this requests or changing
changing
what you're wanting to put what you want
into this uh into this
interim study how does that affect
you're getting
what you want is which one is a bill
well just ask me
or ask somebody else on here that's
that was in fact going to be my response
to you is that um I don't think it's
necessary to use the same structure of
this bill to move this issue forward
um and if there's anyone amongst you who
would like to uh create an LSR I have
some language in my back pocket that I
would be happy to give you
it says
someone wish to do that
um no I well you know you'd volunteer
for him but uh I mean
don't have
I mean
uh there's there will be somebody on
this committee who will will be
available
I appreciate that and so um again I will
I will suggest that we have language
that we've uh that we have prepared and
I'm happy to send it to anybody who's
interested so um I I will at the
at the at the at the permission of the
chair I'd be happy to send it to the
committee as a whole if you'd like yes
uh why don't you and do that and
uh if anybody who is is interested in it
I'll just add it to my list of 10 10 000
things to do pardon
yep
I'll be happy to pick it up Mr chairman
maybe with my good friend in the corner
we might uh jointly support that
very very good thank you very much I
think you have your uh
you think you have your your P have you
have your uh sponsors thank you very
much I'll be sending you some language
uh this afternoon
okay now getting back to uh
uh
represent representative Smith for a
motion no I'm not making a motion I'm
making a company oh okay
definitely I was thinking uh that
we would recommend for future
legislation and sub and put in uh the uh
LSR or you know the recommend the
legislation that uh Mr deers is
recommending but
um upon real you know I am really
concerned that if we vote to have future
legislation
um it will open up it will make people
start thinking about changing the
process of designating any River as a
protected River and I really do not want
that to change the process to change I
think it has worked well so um whoever
makes a motion for not recommend I would
does anyone wish to make a motion
or your question
I'll make a motion to not recommend for
future legislation
motion made by representative spank
representative Gould
anyway it's just anyone wish to speak on
the motion
uh
representative Spang do you wish to
speak on it uh no I I think that
representative Smith has put it in a
nutshell
thank you and you representative Gould
you wish to speak on your second
okay seeing anyone else wish to speak
seeing no one
will the clerk please call the roll
uh for not recommend on 1620
representative harp yes
representative Huff yes representative
Gould
representative Horrigan
yes representative Creighton yes
representative Dodge yes clerk roads yes
the representative Healy yes
representative Mayville yeah
representative post yes representative
Smith
representative Spang
representative grassy representative
gottling
representative Cohen yes
representative Connors is not here
representative Vale yes
representative Kelly is not here
representative Moran is not here
representative Egan is not here and
represent chair renzulo uh yes
okay so it's 17 to zero motion passes
Mr Diaz are you here for anyone any
other are you here for Senate Bill 257
as well I certainly can be if you wish
to hear additional um information about
that
we do have a
we do have a uh a report a committee
report on that
uh so uh Alaska
recognize representative harp to read
the committee report
thank you Mr chair we did have a
subcommittee on this uh representative
Healy supported local control
representative Harvey bolia spoke about
the Dover pilot program representative
Spang supported local control and spoke
about a few difficulties with the bill
as written representative gottlene
supported the concept and I supported
future discussion regarding nitrogen and
Logan control the vote of the
subcommittee was 5-0 recommend for
future legislation and I make that
motion
first of all
um thank you for the motion after I
recognize you for the most I recognize
you for the motion after I SP uh we hear
from uh Mr dears
thank you very much for the opportunity
to speak on this uh I think that
representative harp uh summed up the the
committee discussion perfectly uh it was
I think it was a very healthy discussion
and uh what this bill would do would be
to provide enabling legislation that
would allow for uh communities to
include septic systems as part of either
storm water or their Wastewater utility
the idea of course that this has
multiple different kinds of effects or
or might be used in different ways one
could imagine an area around a lake
that's not amenable to say sewering to
putting in a sewer system but could have
that group of of people and say a
Housing Development around a lake that
could join together and create a septic
utility that would provide the ability
to have a common pumping schedule to
have a common replacement schedule to
have a very predictable cost associated
with it so that's one way in which you
could see something like this we talked
about the nitrogen issues around Great
Bay that there may be certain
communities that want to include that as
part of their all of the above
approaches to reduce nitrogen pollution
in the Great Bay Estuary and we also
heard
um you know about low-income folks who
might be benefited by having their
communities with the ability to be able
to serve up grants and loans that would
be unavailable to individuals but could
be available through a community to be
able to help low-income individuals that
have failing septic systems these are
all possibilities that could come out of
adopting a a septic utility as part of
some other utility within your community
so I think that that was the the nature
of it but as representative harb so
clearly identified there are some
problems with the language as it as it
exists today in the bill but most of
those problems appear to be rectifiable
so I think that that uh the committee
had a again a healthy discussion about
that and and I think that we agree that
any questions from members of the
committee
uh
yeah we haven't I have a desk for a
motion yet
uh I just is only taught speaking on
Mike
I am
concerned about the amount of power
this bill might give
to certain
well
to Lo till we are not well let me
explain this way we are not a a local
control
State we're
we're the the
municipalities are the are an offshoot
of to the basically the the children of
the state
we local local control can get
if not carefully Managed IT get us into
situations where uh
more Authority is
taken
by those and at the local level than we
really intended
I think we've seen that in
in recent times at least at least I feel
we've that's what's happened in recent
times
[Music]
um
also on the issue of the Great Bay we
have the uh the EPA has
fallen into a lot of money lately I
think if I'm not mistaken you correct me
if I'm wrong I think if as I read the
recent legislation they have uh I think
is it tripled or quadruple the amount of
money that's been uh given to the EPA to
basically around projects and so there's
a lot of money out there
well if I remember the the Estuary issue
you you gave us this pie chart where all
of the things that were going into that
into the bay and all the things that
were causing the problems and the only
one near uh the the EPA was saying to go
after was this little section kind of
con concerning septic systems and not
about anything else
so maybe the if the EPA wants it done
well they should be able to kick up some
more money
and hopefully they will be able to they
have a lot more to give out
let's see if our if our
uh
whoever they whoever they may be our
representatives in at the federal level
should be looking to get something for
the estuary
uh
looking at about a recommendation to
move forward on this uh but however I'm
not
putting pressure on anyone this is
missed me by my myself
so vote your conscience but I will be
uh and
yeah thank you Mr chair
um
the I know that generally New Hampshire
is not a local control State and we do
have some uh items that are uh state has
preemption over like the use of
pesticides and fertilizers towns can't
regulate them but that is because more
so because landscapers or people who
work on projects where those items are
used uh cross lines and are going in all
different towns and then there's
different rules for each town and that
could be problematic but this one
enables towns municipalities to set up a
program for their town
and develop a uh a residential
program a program for the town which
would then help the town to better deal
with this situation and Mr deers just
testified that
low-income people could there could be a
fund developed to help the low-income
people so it was not overwhelmingly
expensive for them and
um the EPA although you know we always
would like more money from them much of
the wastewater treatment plants that are
getting funding this year and last year
it has come from the federal government
so it's in not the state so that's been
we are getting money from the federal
government but I would I believe agree
with representative renzuelo that we
need to do something and that we should
have some future legislation although
this bill is not it I think that's what
you said is it probably yeah but I mean
anyone else wish to speak on the motion
well there is no motion but anywhere
else we should speak on the issue
then grassy yes Mr chairman thank you
um I think what you're looking at here
is a bill and particularly after
listening to the testimony from Mr deers
this bill
even though we are not a local
controlled state
when you're dealing with
this type of an incident with with you
know pollution in the communities each
Community deals with it differently
trying to have regulations across the
state that you know one size fits all is
impossible
and and doesn't always work and
particularly when you're taking a look
at communities that have water bodies
next to them or Coastal communities or
river communities communities need to
take a look at how they deal with
contaminations differently
um and I'm looking at my community of
Rochester now Rochester may or may not
take advantage of this but if we did it
may be a way that we could help reduce
some of the costs that's being inflicted
upon the ratepayers of of because of of
discharges into the uh kachiko river
which go into gray Bay a lot of the
Seacoast communities are being charged a
tremendous amount of money are being
forced to do tremendous improvements to
their wastewater treatment facilities
because of contaminants that are going
into their Rivers which end up in Great
Bay by doing this it would give each
individual Community the ability to deal
with it the way it sees fit so yeah we
we're on a local controlled state but
but we also all talk about local control
that it's nice thing to be able to do
things at the local level instead of
instead of having the state mandate
things to them this is something that
allows communities the options and
another option in dealing with
pollution of of their water supplies and
also the environment
um you know these discharges whether it
be into an aquifer or
you know a river or something that ends
up in Great Bay
um communities need to be able to have
some flexibility in how they deal with
the problem it's not just a mandate that
comes down from the EPA and says you
shall do
let the communities have some
flexibility and this is one way we can
give them flexibility and as was
mentioned by Mr deersen and also
representative Smith
this allows communities also to work
with those people who are less fortunate
who are unable to maybe replace the
septic system by providing resources for
them through grants or loans and I think
this is something that we should
recommend further legislation on this
bill
thank you chair um I did vote to
recommend this in the subcommittee I'm
conf I'm somewhat unsure of uh what
those designations mean but I will be
voting against I will be voting not to
recommend it uh just because of the tax
when it when we heard the hearing you
know when we had the hearing it was
mentioned that the intent was to set up
attacks
for nitrogen on property owners based
upon square footage of of impervious
service surface of the of the particular
properties and I believe this is sounds
like it's going to be very costly to uh
to homeowners it's it's vague
and so those are my concerns I I realize
there's a nitrogen issue but having such
a large portion of the nitrogen coming
from rainfall
um
representative Spang thank you um
I regret or that or this is not my bill
but I think it's too bad that it got
tied in with the stormwater utility
storm I was the chair of the commission
that looked at storm water and came up
with this is the ideal uh solution
but I think that it has Led Led our
committee to confuse what's happening
here with the way a storm water utility
is set up to work first of all
no storm water utilities have been
approved for any municipality in the
state of New Hampshire yet
so I think if this were to to
were to be implemented it would depend
upon the stormwater utility I think what
Mr deers has says is saying that there
are a lot of other things that could
come out of this type of approach that
would have nothing to do with the
stormwater utility it would have nothing
to do with attacks
at all it would have nothing to do with
the amount of square footage of
impervious that all relates to the
stormwater utility which I think
uh obviously needs to be struck out of
this approach
what Mr dears is pointing out is that
there's a lot to be explored in terms of
how we're going to deal with these uh
failing septic systems or particularly I
think someone was mentioning at the
hearing about little neighborhoods where
the whole neighborhood
has failing systems
and something needs to be done
collectively perhaps but it has nothing
to do with setting up a stormwater
utility
also just setting up if an organization
was set up
um
might be called a utility but I don't
see any reason why it should be where it
would be a structure where money could
come in from the state and the federal
government to then be given out to
people who need that money to pump their
septic systems to deal with failing
septic systems or to perhaps set up a
a neighborhood septic system a
collective septic system so that has
nothing to do with any taxes whatsoever
I think that given the number of things
that Mr deers
outline for us of way that we could be
helping to deal with these septic
systems all over town some of them
Collective some of them are probably
because of the financial disability of
people to deal with their systems that
that whole situation or condition that
he is outlying is right for us to be
coming up with some idea about how to
work more collectively to deal with
these
hmm
thank you uh anyone else wish to speak
if
seeing no one else
uh you've
uh representative harp for a motion
thank you Mr chair I'll again motion uh
representative Creighton for us for a
second
uh with the speaker in your motion yes
briefly thank you
um as was mentioned as written I would
not support this bill but it has a
flavor and a concept concerning certain
items that I think should be addressed
and future legislation and which I think
we're probably going to see so that's
why I made the motion to recommend for
future legislation thank you
right seeing no one anyone else wish to
just want to speak on your uh
on your motion no I just think it's an
opportunity to move forward and it's a
good start okay
Representatives Smith did you wish to
speak so the the motion is to recommend
for future legislation yep oh okay
on the motion what was this clerk please
call the roll
yes a motion to recommend 257
representative harb yes
representative Huff is not present
representative Gould
representative Horrigan
representative Creighton
representative Dodge yes
the clerk votes no representative Healy
yes representative Mayville
representative post yes representative
Smith
representative Spang
representative grassy yes
representative gottling
representative Cohen yes
after them Connors is not present it was
unveil yes
uh representative Kelly is not present
representative Moran is not present
representative Egan is not present and
representative renzulu no is no
is that enough harp you'll write the
report
is that I I think that's it very uh
are you Mr dears
it can go and have a heavy drink thank
you very much I appreciate the
opportunity to be in front of you and
and to those who are uh for whom this is
their last executive session
um I wish you all well it has been truly
truly spectacularly fun to uh to serve
here with you and I applaud your your
service to the state thank you so much
thank you very much thank you very much
for your help uh let's back up uh now
for uh
uh let's see we've got remember the
house bill uh 1641 FM uh
representative Creighton you are
reporting
yes Mr chairman
um we met last week regarding this uh
had extensive testimony from Captain
Dunleavy the bottom line is that as a
result of the the testimony we recommend
going forward with Captain Donald's
proposed legislation for a commission to
study the issue
essentially uh New Hampshire is out of
compliance with federal law regarding
um red voter registration
because uh portions of our registration
go to Des fish and game and the Peace
Commission that is Those portions are in
violation of federal law
uh so what the sub to me looked at was a
two-prong approach uh one cabin done
lady is working with Federal uh
legislatures uh specifically Senator
Sheen's office
to get uh the federal law modified so
that the seven states that are out of
compliance can fall in compliance now
that is an ongoing discussion between
the state of New Hampshire the Coast
Guard and the uh and the senator
uh by the same token the Coast Guard
requires us to move forward to fall
within the existing laws
uh and cam don't let these team has come
up with uh a way ahead
um and so what we want to do is to
codify that uh with a commission that
would help New Hampshire resolve
um
the conflict under the existing laws and
so the subcommittee recommended 5-0 uh
to proceed with legislation to recommend
is there anyone else wish to speak on
the well this we're not you you haven't
made a motion have you no uh just to
speak on the issue does anyone wish to
hear from the captain uh I think Captain
is if you have anything more to to
give that as hasn't been covered by uh
by representative Creighton
thank you Mr chair no I don't want he's
eloquently put it uh out before you
today summarize what we've discussed in
the past
um and
um we would appreciate any support you
could offer okay and well we this
as you recall uh we we heard your
testimony originally on the on this bill
even though the bill had nothing to do
with what uh what you were asking for
but it sounded like an important thing
to do because you were you the Coast
Guard was was uh I would say harassing
you but they were they were serious they
were expressing their concerns and uh I
think we were able we did this uh We've
do we adopted this uh to be able to
first of all to get the
the issue to get to to show the Coast
Guard that something is happening and I
guess something is happening and
so thank you for your efforts and uh
we're glad to I think we're glad to be
supportive uh is there any other
questions or any uh by or comments by
members of the committee
if not
will clerk please call well let me make
a motion first what do you mean make a
motion I'll recognize representative
Creighton for a motion yes Mr chair I
move that we uh move forward we
recommend further legislation on Bill
1641. can I second it seconded by
and
a second
no
um briefly I would say that as chair of
the Aquatic uh exotic weeds and species
committee we had a meeting Monday and at
the last meeting that we had in
September Captain Dunleavy explained
this whole uh history with us and uh we
agreed at our meeting earlier this week
that we would probably
um once we saw the legislation come out
in full support of this as a committee
anyone else
speak on the motion if not will the
clerk please call the roll
thank you to recommend on Bill 1641
representative harb yes
representative Huff is not present
representative gold
representative Oregon
representative Creighton yes
representative Dodge yes the clerk votes
yes representative Healy yes
representative Mayville
representative post yes representative
Smith
representative Spang
representative grassy yes representative
gottling yes
representative Cohen yes
representative Connors is not present
representative Vale
yes
Kelly is not present and representative
Moran is not present representative Egan
is not present and representative
renzulu yes
16-0
motion passes okay
thank you very much
uh
for off Highway recreational vehicles
and snowmobiles
uh
or anyone wish to make a motion on that
I'll make a motion to not recommend for
not recommend
um I have a second by representative
Spang
okay uh do you wish to speak on your
motion of course thank you Mr chair
um when this when we voted on this bill
earlier uh the legislature was in
um the midst of passing uh House Bill
1188 which sets up a long-term
commission to study ohrv statutes in
this state and representative Egan who
sponsored this bill thought that the
commission to do this would have more
time and could address this issue and
set up a safety program and in listening
to comments from the stakeholders that I
have spoken with and representative
renzulu I believe met with the ohrv
community last week this is something
that is going to take all the
stakeholders coming together so then
rather than having another yet another
piece of ohrv legislation that the ohrv
commission could take this on and get it
so that's why I would say to not
recommend for future legislation because
the issue is already being
going to be taken care by the commission
which is now law and getting ready to
representative spank speak in your
second
these
where's my nitroglycerin tablets
the pigs are flying
all right uh is there anyone else wishes
to speak on this
I I did as uh the
the maker representative Smith uh as as
said I did meet with uh some of some of
the people on uh who are part of this uh
this the proposed commission who were
interested to find out about what the
the issues are where we stood on this
bill and we will be setting up a
subcommittee of that commission at least
that's going to be the proposal that the
subcommittee of the where work on the
work on the substance of the bill
because there were there were a lot of
issues that have to have to be worked
out uh among this among the stakeholders
so
with that if there's no one else clerk
please
call the roll
thank you I'll not recommend for House
Bill 1498 representative harb yes
representative Huff is not present
representative golds
representative Horgan
representative Creighton yeah
representative Dodge yes click votes yes
representative Healy yes representative
Mayville
representative post yes representative
Smith
yes representative Spang yes
representative Grassi
representative gottling yes
representative Cohen yes representative
Connors is not here representative Vale
yes
representative Kelly is not present
representative Moran is not president
and representative Egan is not present
and the chair yes
okay
and
you think we're at we are on the last
one am I not bacon right which would be
SB 258
uh relative to the graves of African
Americans alive during the period of
American enslavement chair recognizes
uh well before we get into this uh I
recognize before I recognize you is
there any discussion we want to be or
anyone we want us to hear from from the
audience I don't think there is anyone
uh on the uh on the on this bill I'll
recognize uh representative grassy uh
promotion thank you Mr chairman uh
you're recognizing you're recognizing me
for a motion I'll move to uh recommend
for further legislation right now also
you have a
uh you're you're going to write or the
uh yeah Mr chairman yeah the the
committee uh heard extensive testimony
on this uh and particularly from the
folks at historic resources and the
municipal Association and uh we were
also given examples such as the uh
the situation which occurred in in
Portsmouth where Graves were discovered
and they were the way the the remains
were handled and reinterred uh they felt
that the process was was an excellent
process to use and they would they felt
that this bill helped um codify uh the
process for dealing with these Graves
um the recommendation of the committee
was to recommend for further legislation
but I think that the the one problem
that we had is that we could not agree
on what that was uh to be I fully expect
that the sponsor will be reintroducing
this bill next session and I would hope
that the committee would look at it
favorably and work on our differences to
try to work something out there was a
lot of discussion about
um you know that all people should be
dealt with equally what is the
interesting thing here is that when
discussions particularly with the folks
from historic resources uh spoke it was
that
people of African descent were not
treated as humans they were treated as
property many of them are not buried
within any well-identified cemetery plot
or Apostle and you they tend to be found
everywhere
um and similar to the way indigenous
people are found in many cases and there
are a number of cases historical
resources state that there were you know
certainly this is something they deal
with a lot when they find these Graves
and a lot of it is just folklore
sometimes that they find that a certain
person had a farm he owned a number of
slaves here in New Hampshire and that
they are buried somewhere in the field
on the back of the field they're the
back 40 and that we needed to have
special considerations because the way
that a lot of these African
Aerials where there were very ceremonial
and that in order to deal with them we
need to deal with them differently than
we deal with others uh particularly
European descendants and
um you know when they were found working
with The Descendant Community was quite
important when they deal with an
indigenous person they deal with The
Descendant Community uh being the Indian
tribes that are in the area dealing with
with those people and and what they
would would be very interested in
working is is to work with the
African-American descendant community in
the reinternment of many of these uh
bones that are that are discovered
so it was recommended further
legislation we couldn't agree on what
that legislation may be but I think that
the the committee overall did uh agree
anyone else
representative uh Creighton and
representative uh uh Cohen
yeah
yeah I completely agree with what
representative grassy uh indicated as
the results of the subcommittee meeting
uh I do believe that that language is
possible that would be acceptable all
um and I think we should work on that
um we'll figure something out I think
uh
representative Cohen and representative
representative post yeah I'm definitely
in favor of this bill in some form I
think we promote and we legislate to
Value diversity in New Hampshire I think
this is a foundation for making up for a
problem that might exist and not reflect
positively on valuing diversity here in
the state so I'm definitely in favor of
pushing this board and having it looked
at as what if there's tweaks in the
future
uh representative post thank you Mr
chair I just want to say um the
historian Ben Wilson spoke to us and uh
he was going to look up some information
we had questions on that I think will be
helpful in creating legislation thank
you
uh is there anyone else represent
representative
Veil
thank you Mr chair this was a
fascinating hearing it went on for a
couple of hours great hearing it was
great it really really was and I just
want to reiterate when we met with the
gentleman who testified at length from
cultural resources this happens monthly
that they you know discover someone and
um the man he he was very good at
discussing what the chain of custody is
for a corpse that is found or a skeleton
or whatever it might be and how
important it is to get that to their
next person and so I'm thinking about it
like be laying it to the correct culture
and I really really appreciate what
representative Cohen said because the
diversity is something that we are
working at so hard right now and it
really does recognize that there's a
specific situation in this culture and I
would hope that we would always look at
cultures and think about their specific
situations the way that we have this one
thank you so much Mr chair
anyone else wish this uh wish the
speaker observed I will uh I'll give I'm
going to give my two cents
[Music]
um
the first of all the hearing that we had
I wish the people who were testif had
testified had been at our original
hearing uh you really uh we learned a
lot at least I learned a lot I think
most everyone else
there learned a heck of a lot I think it
started one of the with one of
Representative Creighton's just said it
started off with what happens if I find
a skull in my yard I mean and uh well
you know and
it was quite uh quite an education and
uh and a lot of good back back and forth
I think one of the things that to me
what I saw and found was that instead of
focusing this the issue on one specific
group of people
it would have been better
to have raised the is raised the uh
the the treatment of
uh Graves uh opened and of of these of
individuals individual Graves
raised them to a certain a specific
level
that commensurate with the fact that
they are
our history
they are the graves is is where most of
our history is in it ends up buried
and
our knowledge comes much of archeology
comes from grapes uh that we should
treat them all with the same level of
respect
uh unfortunately I feel that
we by
focusing on one specific group
we're not we're getting we're we're
we're not giving equity
to the all the other groups who may have
similar feelings treat all the same
that's that's how that's what I felt
should uh we should have come out with
we did not we came up specifically with
uh it was that was not undertaken by the
by the vote I don't I don't believe
uh however
so I I voted against the uh the
recommendation to uh but I'm going to
change my vote and I will uh I will
recommend I will vote to go on because I
uh because I think there is it it's
important that
we try that I will try to my best to
change this
to a bill that recognizes
the same Dignity of all people and
treatment of all people with the uh with
uh that there that gray whose graves are
being moved
and uh or graves are found uh you I
think also uh We've the issue was
if you read the bills the bill was
focused on
a a segment that was focused on the very
the most extreme ends where you find a
body in the woods or something to uh to
a cemetery where someone is has been
buried and and stay in Past Times
and there's a whole wide spectrum in
between we concentrated mostly on the
initial finding of the finding of
uh of air of graves that we didn't know
were there
and that so we we did miss the
discussion on the other end of the
spectrum but other than that uh I I
think we did a lot of work and I thank
the work the the uh Mr Wilson for his
Ben Wilson from the cultural resources
for doing a fantastic job of of
educating us on what he has to do and it
was very very interesting and I if you
get a chance it says if it's on the
YouTube you might want to listen
to it uh
is there any other comments
please not well clerk please
oh uh
is that your your second
let's post will the clerk please call
the roll
okay on uh to recommend House Bill 258
FN representative harb yes
representative puff is not present
representative Gould
representative four again
representative Creighton representative
Dodge yes clerk votes yes representative
Healy yes representative Mayville
representative post yes representative
Smith
representative Spang
representative grassy
representative got link
representative Cohen yes
representative Congress is not here
representative Vale yes
representative Kelly moriana Egan are
not here representative friend Zulu yes
is there any other business
before the committee
representative Cohen
I just want to address the committee and
thank them for some of the work we've
done this year I'm I have chosen not to
run for reelection so I will not be
serving on this committee next year but
I know it's been a trying year between
uh the Republican Democrats in general
but in this committee most people are
similar in thoughts in perfecting the
environment and I think it's a good
example of bipart a lot of bipartisan
work and cooperation discussions going
on and I just thank you for that and
wish those that are coming back next
year in both parties to uh continue that
and the best of luck to you thank you
very much
is there anyone else who wishes to uh
yes
that's right those are mines so yeah
what would you do it there
on my desk
but thank you very much representative
Spang and uh uh
yes yes thank you Mr Chim
um yeah I I think that you know
certainly we're all going to miss
Judith's brownies but I think one of the
things we're going to miss more as well
is that we have a number of members who
are leaving this year that have a
tremendous amount of talent and
knowledge about the issues that we deal
with this is my third term on this
committee and I'm looking around the
room and everybody else on this
committee except for the three who three
of who are leaving us
have less time than I have on this
community and yourself Mr chairman I
neglected you intentionally but you know
I don't want you to get upset the the
three members three members and and not
to belittle certainly Mr Cohen next to
me but the three members that we have
that are leaving us have years and years
of experience on this committee that I
know I will certainly Miss and I'm and
and it's something that we cannot
replace and uh you know that I want to
thank them for the years that they put
in here and all the Talking that Judith
has done I you know
it's a personal joke between her and I
but uh the the thing is is that you know
they're just so invaluable and and I I
don't know I I need to get you on speed
dial because I know if I'm here back
next year here as well I will be calling
you frequently you know particularly
when it comes to oh RVs which you know I
need you know we need that we need that
those those these people here and we're
losing them this year so thank you for
before I say something
go right ahead all right
um I've been serving on this committee
for 10 years I've been the chair I've
been the ranking member I've been the
vice chair and one of the things that
and before that I was on environment and
agriculture for two terms I learned from
the chair and the ranking member on that
committee the advantages and the
benefits to everyone on the committee
when the chair and the ranking member
can get along and work together to
develop good policies and not put
politics first but put policy first and
I think that what I learned on Ena and I
brought over to resources and since that
time it's been just a pleasure to serve
on this committee and work with all of
thank you
[Applause]
and anyone else yes I'll have to say
something thank you yeah
well I've been on this committee 12
years
and one segment of two years when I had
a Hiatus I still came down and testified
and had other people putting my bills in
and I would say you know some of our Big
Adventures were wild goose and which was
an unending Saga finally settled and I
was able to do a lot of things for my
Lake community
and that was really really important and
and representative renzulo I'll probably
if you're back here which I suspect you
will I'll be down sitting out there and
uh you know encouraging you you know
yeah but like that right yeah pointing
your fingers yeah and and and you know
the one thing that's sort of too bad
from my point of view is that because of
covid
I did not get to know the uh
Republican members of this committee as
well as I might have liked to and that
was uh sort of that that I think was in
for unfortunate because I always enjoyed
and felt it was important to work with
the other part of the committee whether
we were in charge or we were not in
charge
and it was
my privilege always to be able to find
bipartisan sponsors of bills and I hope
you'll all keep doing that I'm sure you
will
Representatives Bank I've served on this
committee for 22 years
um
one
once I guess it was two years maybe as
chair
and
um it's always been it's always been
really fun I enjoy natural resource
issues so I really enjoyed all of the
people that have been working with me on
at DES and Dread Etc and EPA but also
the members of the committee I have
worked for decades on land protection
and I remember talking to one of my my
colleagues my older colleagues who had
been at it much longer than I about dang
it that's a really important piece of
property and she she keeps saying she
wants to conservative and she never does
and he smiled at me and he said Judith
this you're in it for the long run you
know things good things will eventually
happen you know the the time and the
effort that you have put into it
um will over time have some effect
and I'm thinking that this committee is
the same that because we haven't had
much time to get together and to share
thoughts and opinions and information
perhaps it's going to be a longer term
for everybody on this committee is as
comfortable with with these issues and
with the people we work with as those of
us who have served for a longer time but
I welcome you to that Journey you will
really enjoy it you'll find that your
opinions about things and your
understanding of issues will draw
together closer and closer as time goes
on and this and the state of New
Hampshire will very much profit from it
foreign
I'm losing friends
and
maybe that's what uh that's what you
build here you build relationships
and
I've had relationships with friendships
with
the Spang the bottling you know all of
you and of course with representative
Smith uh and you learn from them I mean
I've been here uh well I've been here
now
uh this is my eighth term going on nine
maybe unless unless unless they uh the
voters catch up with me uh but the uh
I've learned that I've
said you know seven of those years have
been uh seven of those terms have been
here and uh once once I got here
I stayed because it was it was the best
committee I've learned so much uh I've
learned I've learned so much from
representative Smith
uh mostly how to you know
I'm a I'm a political person if you look
at my if you look if you look at my
record here I've been a deputy uh you
know whip I've been floor leader I've
been uh all of that's all those things
on the political end only twice have I
been chair
and this is one of them and uh I
it's a diff it's a being a being
legislative as opposed to political is
very different
and it was a change for me to an EXT to
an extent because uh you when you pull
it when you legislative you have to
have to put in all people's ideas and
representative Smith taught me that so
I'm glad she's going to be around on the
uh
on the the
ohrv committee Commission because
she believed she got the temperament for
but uh but other than other than that I
can go on for an hour but I won't uh
but
for those of not coming back
our mission
you guys will come back you wish I left
thank you
does anybody else have something they
wish to say
is that an Avail
um thank you Mr chair I just want to say
that when I don't know why we do what we
do and we do so many things for a reason
and those reasons are based on
institutional history that can never be
replaced
and um I mirror and Echo what
representative grassy has said I would
like to have everyone on speed dial
but
on the other hand I feel like if you get
away you get away so I'm gonna let you
get away but if you if if you're leaving
and you want to get involved on the many
commissions that we have that's a good
way to stay in touch if you want to but
thank you so much I feel so blessed to
have worked with you as a returning
member I feel so blessed to have seen
friendly faces when I came back in 2018
and I just
what
brownie time it's brownie time we are
adjourned